signori siamo ritornati sul gioco del
millennio proprio quello che ti fa
capire cosa serve la scuola niente
quando ci sono i giochi erano rimasti ad
un punto preciso
continuiamo dall'inps coop è l'ultimo
livello questo ragazzi l'ultimo livello
prima del finale che questo nella
discoteca mi spiegate mi da una
discoteca io come posso arrivare
all'oceano va bene proviamoci ragazzi ve
lo giuro
un giorno tornerò e mi libererò è una
promessa
credetemi le scale e poi muoio allora
devo uscire di qua devo fare un bel
salto ok favelas
ecco non ci credo sono entrato ed evo
devo schivare la gente che balla stai
dicendo questo è veramente lo credo
proprio ci provo ragazzi non so quanto
sia fattibile veloci prof
vai e non ci passa ma forse non devo
passati quando no devo passare i lascia
un circuito che a te senti no no no no
per fermati oro anzi io ho io la gente
la oggi in discoteca la odio guardate
metri state a casa cordate nestris avete
rotto i trequarti
oddio mio a vedermi nel primo salto easy
è il resto che è difficile poi cambierei
anche un po la musica è roba demonio in
discoteca c'è una teca con un pesce che
avanza nessuno dice niente neanche uomo
sono passati quasi operose balli e un
problema soprattutto contro muro
invisibile o che ci sono ci sono shore
sono ce l'ho fatta e dove l'hai preso
non è non me la prezzo non era preso
riprenderci e point verrà preso la preso
lamela ha preso social point lo so devo
andare andare sotto le scale va bene ma
mi sa che devo superare le scale ok poi
mi prende c'è point
scale ok ma amano giù per le scale piano
piano che un casino piano piano piano
piano mio dio questo gioco ed ex
training di più diablo quattro mesi
eccoci bene adesso cosa devo fare
a darlo passare dietro al bar va bene
mazza che brutta st discoteca devo
andare avanti non so davvero come mai
hai dei panni stesi in una discoteca zio
illuminami ti prego allora mi sa che
devo fare un giro piuttosto largo e
piuttosto angusto questi qua comunque
palle bravo il moonwalk al a michael
jackson bravissimo d'occhio occhio
occhio che occhio occhio occhio brava
grazie della spinta sono vivo ciò solo
poca acqua ma sono vivo sono sono più o
meno sono morto maledizione
devo rimanere con abbastanza acqua per
muovermi sono muoio il problema è che
quando arrivò qua c'è gente inizia a
correre come se volesse dar fastidio
sono ancora in piedi ma ci sono vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai lì c'è point a
sinistra a sinistra va bene
cerri voce di mocerivò è arrivato ho
fatto l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso è
mio è mio stessa croce point ma torna
raga mamma mia non mi chiedete come non
lo so mi piace subito al video la strofa
subito il mi piace voglio l'ho preso
volando c'è poi tokyo e vabbè allora se
non mi fai frenare come si frena
chissà che devo andare mi sa che forse
non devo scendere da lì
così madonna che brutti siete vado ok
devo rallentare fortissimo perché sono
muoio ok a posto è perfetto treni
funzionano
devo fare la stessa cosa qua immagino e
non vedo dove sono girato che l'affetto
la nostra amata rallenta rallenta
rallenta rallenta rallenta rallenta la
mente
ok adesso come muoio se faccio lo faccio
lavora con loro dai mi devo infilare in
mezzo probabilmente ok perfetto noi devo
girare anche mentre gira loro loro per
loro è tutto tranquillo ed è succede
sempre ogni sabato sera qua dentro è
tutto perfetto sempre così check point e
prendi melo
ok perfetto devo andare ragazzi vestiti
di un po meglio la prossima volta grazie
credo di dover fare il giro lungo tanto
per cambiare bella la discoteca comunque
un pesce in discoteca proprio l'ultima
cosa che volevo vedere nella mia vita
però va bene bene f buoni bravi come ti
amo come ti amo come tele limone quale
la brucia e la pesce non si può fare
questo non so se lega e avanti mica è
entrato cr7 o soffitto ma cos'è il resto
ed è ma come era è un ratatouille in un
po diverso ecco barbapapà cosa va bene
da va bene va bene facciamo domande dove
vado dove devo andare io non so cosa
dire quello di una cosa sto facendo sta
succedendo ma che idea incredibile hanno
avuto quelli visto gioco vai vai vai non
devo andare di qua sicuro ma non posso
morire sono dentro una persona al
massimo mi spingono a madonna che fatica
che fatica quanto sono ubriaco e voi
deve entrare ha dentro
immagino sia l'unica porta che vedo che
il papa ha capito che se deve succedere
devo vomitare nel bagno scommetti o
pisciare
immagino vomitare perché come lo espelle
quello dal vabbè mi chiamo nel bagno
eccolo è stato il bagno è vuoto è un
fantasista gioco o no no no no non per
terra non per terra
no eccoci siamo tornati qui sono io a
posto però è dov'è il bagno giusto
immagino sia e non so qual è il bagno
uno vale l'altro
apro questo e non so quale sia eccolo
e meno male che era questo perché
l'altro era sbagliatissimo perfetto bene
sono quasi fa ora è non c'è dice point
attenzione ragazzi se non c'è qui è
grave perché potremmo dire no invece no
e invece lo fa lo fa lui proprio lui
madonna propulsione era ragazzi
l'esperto delle dei pesci se mi
meraviglio ragazzi ho finito tutti e tre
livelli city co suburbia club bernard
shaw vero che questi tre livelli di aim
fish vi siano piaciuti io sono pesce che
ancora meglio come tito gioco dell'anno
proprio mai vista una roba così
bellissimo ci vediamo a un prossimo
video ragazzi iscritti al canale si
accede al campo nella prima giornata e
come sempre ce la possiamo vita bella
ragazzi
[Musica]